non ho neanche abbiamo iniziato che
subito ci mettiamo a mangiare con
secondo non sono avvelenati panini lo so
che avevate paura di questo test è
sfondato il bel po perché serve del
tempo prima che il veleno entra in
circolo ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
puntata di cucina buttata oggi faremo
una ricetta mini abbiamo fatto un sacco
di cose giganti abbiamo fatto un sacco
di cose nella loro dimensione naturale
ma adesso realtà il momento di iniziare
ad andare verso l'atomo perché avremo
degli hamburger tipo con gli americani
per fare i mini hamburger avremo bisogno
di palle di carne bacon cibo per pecore
altro cibo per pecore real tra ceva per
pregare e mangiate quadrate pomodorini
piccoli cetrioli in salamoia e pane che
lui santo e salse anche filo
interdentale di legno il motivo per cui
facciamo oggi questa ricetta è legato
fortemente al canale noi abbiamo più
soldi per poter rendere delle cose della
loro dimensione naturale visto che le
persone non si iscrivono e quindi sto
decidendo anche di trasferirmi ho già
chiesto a polly pocket di darmi una
delle sue abitazioni in queste purtroppo
una situazione alla quale ci troviamo da
un po forse voi potreste aiutarmi con un
piccolo gesto riuscire a fare qualcosa
di grande un clic su quel cazzo bottone
fusco iscritti iscriviti
non è difficile cioè proprio sotto a
questo video è proprio facilissimo anzi
vi dirò di più per facilitarvi proprio
questo compito da qualche parte qua ho
qua c'è la cartella iscriviti potete
cliccare e iscrivervi e rendermi felice
grande il discorso di riuscire
la ragione è ragione deve dire grande
grande
quindi se durante questo video avrete
seguito questa mia richiesta scrivete
sei grande grande grande come te sei
grande e solamente per tutto il resto
avete la possibilità come sempre di
lasciarci qua sotto delle richieste su
quello che vi piacerebbe vedere
all'interno di questo canale mi
raccomando se avete dei format che vi
piacerebbe vedere non sono proprio delle
singole ricette scrive del 5 a sotto
perché tendenzialmente non abbiamo
vedere che siamo contenitori vuoti
una ricetta abbastanza facile perché noi
cerchiamo in ultimo di complicarci la
prima cosa che ho fatto è stato
acquistare dei panini al latte che sono
i knicks che oggi meravigliose che mi
ricordano il tuo cervello anche però che
quello di cuba di supermario sarebbero i
mostri quelli che si avvicinano e citato
sopra i funghetti di supermario si
occupa che però non gli addominali che
non avrò mai di carboidrati di mostre
taglio al rialzo consiglio spassionato
personale uno alla volta fare i
primattori attori
anzi attori insieme veramente
imbarazzante di questi panini che faremo
ne vorrei fare uno speciale già da
subito che lo dico anche sarà il mio
provato a tagliare in tre parti big mac
bravissimo quindi è un leader vecchi
little mac così l'impreciso unito
gianmarco un attimo rimborsi subito un
attimo a scaldarsi natalia attori altro
prendete intentato che trovate al
supermercato o ancora meglio dal vostro
macellaio di fiducia o dal supermercato
con un macellaio di fiducia da macellaio
con un supermercato di fiducia una
fiducia con un supermercato prendete le
palline e le più citate con le dirà così
ragazzi e fate un esperimento di
larghezza il mio consiglio è quella di
farla uscire leggermente perché tanto
persistere
una volta fatto tutto quanto avrete più
o meno questo tipo di hamburger in hindi
mette una parte e passiamo come potete
immaginare questo non può entrare qua
dentro strabordi rebbe completamente
quindi che cosa devo fare
andiamo a creare delle mini sottili ne
prendiamo e sottilette e con le forbici
andiamo ad e così senza manco in questo
modo mantengono una forma le potete
mettere una sopra l'altra però così devi
levare quattro volte dell'asti chili in
più e un cognome ben celate
completamente quello che ho fatto
aprite le plastic in e tirate fuori una
sola volta e formali e tagliatelo in
quattro però è più facile con un
coltello tagliarlo oddio non so farne
decisamente tutto si è comunque fine
dovreste trovarvi con questi gare cali
nel facili ma d'impatto passiamo a
questo proponiamo sulla griglia 1234567
che me frega ma che ci importa se lotta
al vino ci ha messo l'acqua e noi e di
molte noie famo cioè messo l'acqua in un
tè paghiamo ma per ovvi per descrivere
la cipolla ronde l'email chiffon la
palla quando fai blog ma credo che abbia
sbattuto sul vetro un calabrone di
queste menti italia sangue manico
manconi magnit e posso dire che la
moglie può anche andare ben coach scotto
bene nel medio e la cottura perfetta io
sono un carnivoro
enrico la dieta non ci sono se volete
anche voi carico su cace no qua sotto la
zona di assemblaggio di hamburger
bisognerebbe vedere l'organizzazione si
è marco ragazzi non vedono di vedere
ufficio posso dire il nuovo set sara pur
li sa se volete vedere il nuovo set
mettete un laico a questo video o li a
spero vi piaccia a me piace da morire
ragazzi sono diventati minuscoli se un
burger
non li sala durante perché sennò mi
perdono troppo su cose sali la carne
durante poi questa qui inizia a perdere
tutti perché una carne dovresti
tendenzialmente bloccarla quasi
cicatrizza tutti i lati in modo che
dentro per pelli tutte so che ci dice
sigillare a sigillare che ringrazio
enrico ora puoi continuare a riprendere
facendo silenzio ma passiamo al bacon
questo qua diventa infinitesimale questo
mette da parte per mangiar velo in altre
occasioni se fai una cosa così per un
aperitivo a casa sei l'eroe nazionale
del buon gusto e dell'accoglienza
passiamo al bacon occhio non bruciarlo è
che questo è una sottiletta cielo manco
se lo mangia lui e croccante non
carbonizzato come tirata guglielmo
fugacemente bruciato come è ben presente
questo semmai mi ha voluto anch'io
gianmarco non lo so io ho sempre il
terrore di quello che viene scritto nei
commenti tipo ora tu morirai piacere
mangiato il gesto io preferisco fare
altro con quel gesto l'ho capita io ha
praticamente mi piacerebbe di più per il
manico ora ai capi da ragazzino continua
a dire a noi dobbiamo aprirci un
ristorante nostro mi piacerebbe se
esistesse un ristorante cucina buttata
dove venite
e ci siamo noi ma 30 set no non mi va di
avvelenare proprio la gente però magari
facciamo anche tipo dei corsi di cucina
con gli chef che vengono ospiti per fare
i corsi cucina persegue nei fatti da me
ok fermate le ferite andiamo a tagliare
i nostri cetriolini abbiamo qui il
piatto col padre il piatto con le carni
il nostro piatto con cipolla pomodoro e
cetriolini i nostri formaggi e due tipi
di insalate diverse andiamo ad
assemblare ragazzi in base dei carnet
per tutti
se volete l'opzione vegetariana invece
ai prendetevi come sono le melanzane
quelli allungate tagliati tagliate a
rondelle e usate al posto di hamburger
e qui ti rendi conto aver sbagliato
tutto sotto ma isolata come se non fosse
successo niente e chiamò per prima cosa
le nostre insalatina a questo punto
mettiamo da migliorini forma giazza
[Musica]
cipolla cede clini
salsi chiudiamo
[Musica]
non avevo dentro ci sarebbe stato uno
speciale lo vedete all'interno del
piatto a lui andato un altro strada
andiamo a letto bene quale tu
e per finire stuzzicadenti
[Musica]
quando è carino stupendo poi arrivate a
tavola con lui tipo tenaris il primo
della sua stirpe dai facili da fare è
carinissimo rendi bambini felici è una
bomba dire a questo punto di assaggiare
uno degli assaggi più voluti della
storia ma do un gusto una deliziosi tap
a natale e visiva che solo un po che non
cresce da darmi nella vita gil di paco
buddha sauer che secondo me sono
deliziosi una distrazione anche al gusto
i cani ha promosso ma per poterlo
promuovere abbia passare al pala saggio
di lui il re d'inverno ecco cosa ci dirà
olini con quell'arma maialini in una
salsa pure del più cedolini da un
assurdo ma che te devo dire è per forza
roboni qui non avevo dubbi ragazzo mi
raccomando fate vi anche voi se li fate
pagatemi su in sa però che sono curiosa
di vedermi in fateci sapere se vorreste
vedere altre cose il mini all'interno di
questo canale iscrivetevi come sempre
lasciate su un bel pollice su per il ci
vediamo giovedì con un nuovo video
ciao
[Musica]